La cuenta regresiva está en marcha y
Estados Unidos deberá discutir a
contrarreloj el acuerdo sobre el techo
de la deuda la fecha límite es el 5 de
junio cuando el tesoro se quedará sin
fondos para afrontar pagos pendientes y
el abono de prestaciones sociales pero
el presidente Joe biden es optimista
no hay razón por la que no pueda hacerse
antes del 5 Confío en que obtendremos
una votación en ambas cámaras y ya
veremos
sin embargo el panorama se perfila
complejo tanto biden como el líder
republicano del Congreso Caín mccarthy
deberán negociar con los congresistas de
sus propios partidos Y es que las salas
más duras tanto de los demócratas como
de los republicanos creen que se dieron
demasiado en la negociación este
contexto hace que el acuerdo ya tenga
interrogantes en la primera instancia el
martes será analizado por el comité de
reglas compuesto por nueve republicanos
y cuatro demócratas de esos nueve
conservadores 3 son del bloque más
rígido sumado que los demócratas no
suelen apoyar las propuestas de la
mayoría de superar esta instancia
preliminar el debate llegar a las
cámaras nunca digo que tenga confianza
en lo que el congreso va a hacer pero me
siento muy bien al respecto he hablado
con varios de los miembros hablé con
mcconnell hablé con mucha gente y se
siente bien veremos cuando comienza la
votación
primero será la cámara de representantes
que cuenta con una estrecha mayoría
republicana y luego pasará por el senado
con un exigua supremacía demócrata el
líder demócrata en la cámara alta truck
Summer anticipó que se podría debatir el
viernes e incluso durante el fin de
semana si no hay una cooperación
bipartidista